yeah it's almost like carl cherry's like
the new sk kind of right
or like you know because you would think
like i mean i saw with my own eyes like
if you could get shake or mech to post
your [ __ ] on two dope boys
it literally like will change your life
life changing yeah if sk posted you
forget about it over like at that in the
real like early stages not right was the
blog
period it was not right and then you
know everyone else was coming up and not
right was like the standard like if if
you got on all right it was like oh [ __ ]
this i got it i've listened to
everything on that right i was on that
right three times a week
that's crazy
[Laughter]
every week for the year i was on it
three times a week yeah i mean yeah it
is i missed the era of music because it
did feel like those guys had like
legitimate
love for
quality
and i think that
the blog era at least the gatekeepers
in my opinion were the best
gatekeepers we've ever had because they
were the most tuned in and they you know
like i'm real over the years was really
tight with shake and mac and those guys
and like they like genuinely like if
they didn't like your music they didn't
post it yeah and that was that's
different right because now
you're gonna get on a playlist because
it's algorithm or because like you know
even if the song sucks if you're the
bigger name or you got you're on a label
you're getting on rap caviar
even if someone who's running that
playlist is like this [ __ ] is ass
as to where back then i feel like at
least the gatekeepers were like hip-hop
nerds and they wrote about it it was
over and they had a post where they
typed and it was like yo like they took
pride in like help building people's
careers like yeah i owe my own my career
to now right and all of the blogs on
smash 2 boys even world star hip-hop you
don't start yeah they when they first
were starting out you know they were
underneath not right and then you know
the fights helped them but a lot of
times it was the music my freestyles
that would go up there it would help
build up the site you know so you know a
lot of these places was just starting
out even hip-hop dx all hip-hop they
were just starting out